Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue.
Hello friends.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
This is by far the most difficult podcast intro that I've ever recorded.
I've already tried to do it six or seven times and have failed,
so I'm just gonna run with it and the reason for the difficulty will become
super clear quickly.
The guest is Terry Laughlin,
who completely changed my life.
He became a friend,
a mentor.
He taught me how to swim and did it remotely at first through his book,
total immersion when I was in my thirties and fixing that helped me do address
one of my lifelong,
largest insecurities and something that really caused a lot of humiliation for
which was growing up on long island,
being close to water,
having a few traumatic experiences,
and never learning to swim until my thirties and Terry,
you can learn all about total immersion everywhere.
Just search,
total immersion,
swimming,
total immersion.net t I swim on Twitter,
et Cetera,
is really a revolutionary way of learning and teaching.
And he was introduced to me,
or the method total immersion was introduced to me by Chris Sacca,
who's another friend who's been on the podcast,
billionaire investor all around hilarious and,
uh,
intelligent guy who said to me at a barbecue,
I have the answer to your prayers as it related to not being able to swim.
And it turned out to be Terry Laughlin and total immersion.
The reason this is so hard is that I grew to really care for Terry and we did
this interview October 2nd.
Terry had at that time metastasize pancreatic cancer.
Uh,
that was October 2nd.
On October 10th,
he had a stroke and was hospitalized.
And then on October 20th,
10 days later,
he passed away.
I just found out about this yesterday afternoon,
uh,
after getting back from being off the grid,
I turned on my phone and a barrage of texts came in.
And the first one that I saw was from a friend who said,
did you see the news about Terry?
And that makes this what you're about to hear the last long form interview the
Terry ever did in his life.
And it's intended to be inspiring and to showcase a tactically in sincere
teacher,
he developed 24 national champions,
but then turned his eye to the adult population.
People who had given up on themselves,
who had accepted partial completeness,
who thought that learning to swim or x,
Y,
and Z,
whatever you might have in your mind was impossible and taught them to overcome
that.
And
I really view him as the epitome of what I tried to do myself as a teacher.
Whether it is looking at accelerated learning or deconstructing something,
logically sequencing it,
he cares so fucking much.
And that will come across in this interview even if you don't care about
swimming at all.
I encourage you to listen to this for a few different reasons.
Number one,
this is like I said,
the last long form interview Terry did in his life.
And when you listen to this,
you will hear that he is,
it sounds incredibly vibrant and was,
uh,
what I also did a,
and I owe a sincere thanks to his family for sending this to me.
Uh,
it was included audio at the end of the interview and these are clips that,
uh,
within the first few days after his stroke in the hospital.
So a week before he died or so his daughter's Fiona,
Carrie and Betsy,
uh,
recorded audio,
interviewed him following his stroke,
uh,
because he was extremely focused the entire time on the mission of finishing his
current book.
Uh,
so they were asking him questions and pulling out these philosophies of life and
so on in this environment of hospitalized medicine where you have beepers and
you have footsteps and have staff moving around.
And I want you to listen to it because it's fucking heart wrenching.
And I want you to surrender yourself to that sadness and to let it envelop you
and to really listen to it.
It's not intended to impart a ton of super tactical information.
It's intended to make you feel just how painful it is to have time running out.
And I want you to ask yourselves,
because I've written five books now and many people have changed their lives by
testing assumptions and finally doing the things that they have put off,
whether it's quitting something,
starting something,
taking a trip,
forming a company,
quitting a job,
ending a relationship,
proposing to someone,
whatever it might be.
I've seen that,
but I've also seen thousands of people sitting on the sidelines with the a
deferred life plan of some type,
something that they are deferring to someday when it's going to be more
convenient,
which it never will be.
Generally speaking,
there is never a good time to do the things that are most important.
And so I want you to listen not only to the interview but to the clips at the
end there were recorded in the hospital because I want you to extremely acutely
feel in your viscera.
Yeah.
The reality,
which is we are not guaranteed
a long life and I've had several friends die in the last year.
I don't know what's going around in the air,
but several friends die in the last year,
a young and old and people do not die of old age.
They die of disease,
they die of accident,
they die from violence.
There are so many things that you can take you out before you think your
lifespan will end.
So hopefully this interview,
this conversation with the incredible Terry Laughlin can serve as a catalyst for
you to get up off your ass physically or metaphorically speaking and do what it
is you really want to do so that you don't die with a bucket list of things that
have not been checked off.
And that certainly was not Terry Terry squeezed every drop out of his life up
until the very,
very last moments.
And you get to hear some of those moments.
So this
yeah
is really surreal for me and
okay,
I miss him already.
Uh,
so Terry,
thank you for changing my life and uh,
I hope you're swimming far and wide up in heaven.
Uh,
and you know,
he,
he kept in good spirits until the very,
very closing bell and a,
there's actually a piece in outside magazine written by Christie Aschwanden.
I hope I'm getting the pronunciation right.
Who's a lead or the lead science writer at five 38.
And,
uh,
she describes how at,
at the very end,
even at that,
the last time that his daughter Fiona saw him laugh,
was him telling this joke about baseball because he loved baseball.
And He,
and the joke related to two friends who had a pact and the first of them to die
and would return to tell the other whether there was baseball and heaven.
So the first guy dies and he appears to his friend.
The good news he says is that there's baseball in heaven.
The bad news is that you're pitching tomorrow.
Terry thought that was hilarious.
And he was able to find the glimmers of hope and optimism even when he was
literally on his deathbed.
So for the things that you want to do for the things you feel compelled to do,
the things that you've dreamed of for so long,
what is your excuse
for not doing them?
Think about it very,
very carefully and meditate on it because we're all going to die.
It's just a question of when and um,
in any case,
uh,
my apologies for the long introduction,
this has been really difficult for me and this is the best job I can do it with
this one guys.
So please enjoy this wide ranging conversation with none other than the
incredible much beloved and much missed.
Terry Laughlin.
Terry,
welcome to the show.
Thank you for having me on,
Tim.
I've really wanted to do this for quite a while.
Well,
I've wanted to have you on for many,
many years and I thought I would start before we get into,
uh,
the backstory and a,
there's so many different things that we should cover in this conversation.
But I think the most sensible place for a lot of my listeners is where I came in
contact with total immersion.
And I should start by saying,
I grew up on long island for those people who don't know that has to die.
And a,
I was a townie out,
uh,
in Easthampton of all places,
worked in the lobster rolls,
a bus points on,
and I was minutes from the beach my whole life and never learned how to swim
properly until my thirties.
And the,
I suppose the trigger for preventing me to swim,
we're a handful of near drowning experiences,
one at a summer camp.
And,
uh,
it's,
it was always one of my largest sources of embarrassment and,
uh,
one of my greatest insecurities.
And then something happened.
And what happened was,
uh,
this was several,
of course,
several years ago now,
I just turned 40,
but at the end of a January,
I want to say in,
I'm not exactly sure when it was,
2007,
2008 around there,
a friend and I decided to issue each other new year's resolutions because we
realized that without someone to hold you accountable,
very little tends to get done with New Year's resolutions.
So Chris Ashenden,
who's known as the Kiwi,
because he's from New Zealand,
uh,
said that I had to finish an open water one kilometer and that was going to be
in 2008.
So it must have been the very beginning in 2008.
And I then challenged him to go a year without coffee or stimulants,
uh,
because he fed himself a different types of stimulants to stay awake and then
didn't use to boost,
to go to sleep and so on,
which is very,
very normal.
Uh,
but I failed is the short story.
I,
uh,
I at least in the first say half or three quarters of the year,
tried kickboards,
barely moved at all.
And it was extremely humiliating.
And I left a number of classes,
hand paddles,
tried those.
My shoulders felt like they were going to break,
uh,
which led me to believe that swimming could not be low impact and I'd
effectively conceded defeat.
And then I met someone named Chris Saka for the first time who's been on this
podcast and uh,
he is now a very,
very famous investor.
At the time he was just starting his sort of ascension,
his hockey stick,
and he was training for a triathlon.
And we met at a barbecue,
uh,
organized by a guy named Kevin Rose,
who was the first episode of this podcast.
And I told him about how I was failing with swimming when he asked me what I was
up to.
I didn't start there,
but we got there and he said,
I have the answer to your prayers.
It revolutionized how I,
how I,
how I swim.
And that's,
that was his,
this was opening sales pitch.
And that's what got me to Tii and total immersion.
And in the span of,
I'd say around,
you know,
between seven to 10 days with a book,
and this is without even the video,
uh,
went from about a one to two length maximum and swimming in a small kind of home
pool to more than 40 lengths per workout in sets of two to four.
And now fast forward,
I swim for relaxation.
And part of how I chose where I wanted to live a,
here we're recording in Austin,
Texas was its proximity to swimming,
which just is insane.
If you were to try to express that to my say 15 year old self,
20 year old self,
even 30 year old self.
So thank you.
That's a very long winded intro.
But I wanted to give people the context because as Chris,
my friend pointed out,
it's a,
it's a life skill.
It's not just a throwaway decorative skill.
And every time I was on a boat,
I had low grade anxiety.
Every time I was near water or going into water,
I had low grade anxiety and I no longer have that.
So thank you very kindly,
sir.
That's so certainly I'm most gratified.
Uh,
and uh,
let me just,
I'll bet I'll bet you're familiar with deep eddy pool.
I am familiar with deep eddy pool and just down the road from the Magnolia Cafe,
which is run by your friends and um,
and Barton springs to wonderful places.
I love to swim when I visited Austin
and enjoy themselves.
Is it,
that's,
that's the best part.
It's not that you can swim one k,
but that you can take advantage of these lovely swimming holes that are really
unique places and,
uh,
in a,
in a complete way.
And,
and to do it as something that I enjoy.
I mean,
it's something that I seek out.
And uh,
I actually wanted to talk to you more about a couple of plans I have for
swimming after this podcast perhaps.
But the punchline also,
I didn't provide for people,
so I improved my swimming and then I was not able to find an open water race
that was one kilometer.
So instead I swim open water in the ocean on Long Island,
on the beach where I grew up going.
But really going up to kind of my waste most of the time,
and simply went off shore after asking a lifeguard how far away a given house
was and swam parallel to shore in the ocean,
which is pretty murky on that side of things.
Pretty Sharkey too.
And Swim,
uh,
almost a mile.
So that's a lot longer than one kilometer.
And probably the most successful I've ever felt in my entire life.
And that is,
that is there put two in really rarefied company,
Tim.
I mean,
there are not very many people who can swim a mile in a pool,
but to swim a mile and an ocean and it really,
really takes it up another notch.
Uh,
only only 2% is a pretty,
uh,
pretty authoritative estimate that only 2% of American adults can swim as much
as a quarter mile nonstop.
So you're in rarefied company swimming a mile in the ocean?
Well,
I've,
I've lot of room to improve,
but I think that the example of swimming is one for me of a partial completeness
that I accepted and it was an assumption.
Iee,
I can't swim.
I don't swim that I didn't test for very,
very long time and many people accept partial complete,
whether it's being,
say overweight.
Well that's just the way it is.
That's just the way I am.
I'm good at some things.
I'm just not able to lose weight,
whatever it might be.
Or in this case,
say swimming or playing basketball,
it could be anything.
A learning to read.
And I wanted to ask you about just to give an example of how late you can test
the assumptions assumptions.
Uh,
Paul Lorrie or Lorrie,
I guess it is called Laurie.
Yeah.
You're Paul.
Laurie.
Can you explain for the people listening who Paul Lawrie is?
Dr. Paul [inaudible].
Paul is a pretty amazing person.
Um,
to give you an idea,
he retired from,
uh,
he,
he was one of the real pioneering pediatric cardiologists in,
in,
in the field of medicine.
[inaudible].
He was a giant in the field.
Um,
and uh,
he retired from practice as a pediatric cardiologist at age 68 and moved to all
knee from,
from Los Angeles,
uh,
to be close to his daughter.
Uh,
and this is an age 68,
and for the next 25 years,
uh,
he was an emeritus professor at Albany Medical College.
So he taught his final seminar in pediatric cardiology at the age of 93,
which will give you an idea of how unusual he is.
He moved to Newpaltz where I live and into a senior living center called
woodland pond.
And it had a pool,
uh,
it not only had a pool,
it had a,
it had a chorus.
It had,
uh,
a woodshop.
And Paul just decided he was going to take complete advantage of everything that
they had there.
And he had never been very serious about swimming in his life.
So,
uh,
he ordered one of our DVDs at age 93,
and,
and taught himself a pretty serviceable freestyle.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
at,
at 94,
he not happened to knock on our door.
We have an endless pool in our basement.
Uh,
we,
we call it the swim studio,
and we teach,
we teach people from all over the world.
And a Alyse answered the door.
My wife,
Alice answered the door and she said this,
uh,
this very slight,
um,
man drew himself up and says,
I'm Dr. Paul Laurie,
can someone here teach me in effortless butterfly?
So Alice told me about it and our daughter Betsy was going to teach the lesson.
So I showed up,
I had to watch this and I saw a pulse,
one free stomps,
pretty nice.
Uh,
and then he tried a few strokes of backstroke,
a butterfly,
excuse me.
And,
uh,
after watching him swim for about 10 seconds,
I,
I said,
Paul,
I think your net,
your second stroke should be backstroke.
And,
and I,
I said,
I'll offer,
I offered him the ultimate senior discount.
I'll come to the pool at woodland pond at no charge,
uh,
and teach you.
And I ended up teaching him about three or four lessons.
And,
uh,
when he was 95,
we shot,
we shot a video of Poland ice swimming together.
We were doing what we call sync swimming,
where I synchronize my stroke to his,
and I posed the question on the video,
can you tell which swimmer is 62 in which is 95?
Because we looked at identical and just exactly alike.
Uh,
and I was so proud of him,
uh,
and to,
to take this a little further,
uh,
November,
November 18th,
I will be attending his hundredth birthday party and he's still swimming 20
lengths a day.
Wow.
Yeah.
So it's never too late to start.
And,
uh,
so I mean,
it's such a wonderful,
I only knew about 10% of that story.
I definitely didn't know about me showing up at the door.
I'm Dr. Paul Lori,
can you teach me in effortless butterflies?
Amazing.
It was freestyle and backstroke cats.
He's happy with those two strokes.
Now I'll tell you something else.
It's really remarkable about Paul.
So he took his first lesson at 94.
He was still gaining speed at 97.
I don't know if there's another example,
uh,
in physical capability of someone improving,
proving between 80 and 96 and 97.
The way,
the way he timed it was he swam at 20 length routine,
which he continues to this day,
uh,
in,
in the 50 foot pool at,
uh,
at woodland [inaudible].
He does a 20 line routine where he swims to free to labs and free and one of
back until he's done 20 lanes.
And his time for that 20 lane through teen,
uh,
in improved incredibly,
in the first year or so,
but it was still getting faster,
uh,
between,
between age 96 and 97.
In fact,
the day he went,
he improved his time.
At 97,
I got a,
I got a text message from his,
his friend Marilyn Bell,
who's,
Oh,
another fantastic story,
um,
over,
uh,
and,
and she said,
uh,
Paul improved I think is his time.
I think improved it from 13 minutes and change to 1253,
uh,
this morning.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
so I,
I immediately texted back to both of them saying how,
how thrilled I was about that.
And then Paul Paul texted me back and he says,
yes,
I went in with a plan to improve my time.
Now how many people are going to the pool at age 97 with a plan to a plan and a
strategy to improve his time?
And his,
his strategy was that he was going to swim even more quietly than before and you
go faster by swimming more quietly.
I mean,
it's just the,
uh,
the whole unexpected nature of what he did and the unexpected nature of his
strategy.
A very great,
cool story.
You personally start swimming?
Uh,
yes.
well,
my dad started may when I was about eight or nine.
And,
uh,
my,
my very first serious swimming experience was,
was swimming,
uh,
at bar beach on long island.
You were on the south shore?
I was on the north shore.
So,
uh,
in Hempstead harbor on long island sound a bar beach.
And they had,
they had,
uh,
a raft anchored I would guess,
maybe 30 feet off shore,
10 yards or so.
And,
uh,
I used to watch with,
with great Nda,
I used to watch my dad swim out to the,
uh,
to the,
to the raft and beyond.
And,
uh,
he would,
he would come back and he would have me do dead man's float and move my arms in
circles.
And,
uh,
and I would sort of practice in the shallows.
And then one day I just screwed up my courage and decided I was going to make a
try for the,
for the raft.
And I,
you know,
swam as we all do.
When we take that first swim in deep water,
which is frantically,
and,
uh,
I got to the raft,
gratefully pulled myself out,
and then Cole's a lifeguard to bring me back,
escort me back safely as my mother tells me.
Um,
so that was my start.
And then I,
uh,
a pool open.
We didn't have a pool at that time in Williston park where I grew up.
And,
uh,
they opened the pool in 1963 when I was 12,
and I took the Red Cross swimmer course and got my Red Cross swimmer that Aj and
joined the,
the pool,
the swim team at the pool.
And then in eighth grade,
uh,
at Saint Aidens school,
my Catholic Grammar School,
I,
uh,
they announced to try out for the swimming team and there is not a lower,
more grass roots level of swimming than Catholic diocese and
diocese and once a once a year meet.
So they were going to have a few practices and then swim in the diocese and
annual neat.
So I tried out,
I didn't even have to swim the length of the pool.
It was the width of the Farmingdale community college,
a six lane pool.
And uh,
when I,
when I got across the pool,
there was a coach in full clothing,
uh,
in the water next to me who had jumped in,
jumped into a Skorton knee across,
not sure I would make it under my own power.
So needless to say,
I didn't make the cut,
not in what's fishes start.
Uh,
and the guy who cut me is still still alive,
a friend of my parents and,
uh,
and we still laugh about that
suit,
but,
uh,
but then I,
I,
uh,
they had the Red Cross,
50 miles swim chart at the pool as all pools did in those days.
And you could get a badge for,
for swimming 50 miles.
And I had 11 weeks in the summer too,
to swim 50 miles,
who at age 13,
I decided I was going to earn that night.
I discovered I really love the solitude of doing laps and I,
I,
you know,
just through doing the laps to earn the 50 mile badge,
which I did,
uh,
I turned myself into an okay swimmer.
Certainly not one with any sort of the fishing technique,
but,
but one who could,
could swim a mile a day.
Not many people can.
And I managed to turn myself into a mile a day swimmer at age 13.
So let's,
let's flash forward and we can certainly pick up anything in between.
But if we look at say 1972,
uh,
so you,
at that time,
my understanding is begin coaching at the US Merchant Marine Academy.
Correct.
And,
uh,
it was there that you had an epiphany or sort of observed something that would,
that would later very much influence your teaching style.
Uh,
can,
can you tell us about what,
what you learned while You were coaching?
Yeah,
this is,
it's,
it's such,
it's a,
a foreshadowing and an unbelievable for shadowing of,
of how I would spend the next 40 odd years.
Um,
you know,
first of all to preface it,
I have to take note that I had swam for eight years before I became a coach.
Uh,
and I was,
I was a very hardworking,
very frustrated swimmer.
And during those eight years,
I can remember one occasion when a coach said anything to me about technique.
So I got you.
If,
you know,
if,
if you take your cues from what your coaches do,
they put workouts on the board and then said,
ready,
go.
Uh,
and nobody said a word about technique except for this one time where the,
where the Co,
the one of my coaches said,
Laughlin,
you'll never swim fast if you don't move your arms slower.
That was the Lva input I got because I was just,
I was such a high turnover swimmer and I,
you know,
as far as I knew,
how else do you swim fast except by moving your arms faster.
So,
um,
so I had gone through eight years with,
not a word about technique except that one time.
And then I was the coach of the,
the Merchant Marine Academy.
I think I had 12 men and a four lane pool and I gave them a garden variety
warmup of 800 yards and freestyle takes about 10 to 12 minutes to do.
And I watched them from the end of the pool and it's the first time I'm ever
watching swimmers and you know,
where I'm in in the situation or the responsibility,
uh,
of,
of well being responsible for their performance.
And I must've been watching with a keener eye than I ever had before because I
noticed that every swimmer in the pool was asymmetrical.
Those who breathe to the left Torque and twisted in that direction and those who
breathes to the right.
Likewise.
Um,
and it just occurred to me that,
you know,
if the object is to move to the,
to,
to the other end by presumably by as laser line,
that it's not good in every single stroke to be diverting momentum and energy
off to the side.
So I went home that night pondering what I'd,
what I'd seen and what I might do about it.
And I decided that the next morning,
the next day for warmup,
uh,
we were gonna I was going to ask them since it was re related to their
breathing.
I,
I gave him 800 yards of freestyle,
but I said,
I,
I'd like you all to breathe on the wrong side.
And because we all start our swimming with a right side,
it was aside on which we are naturally more comfortable and the other side,
we don't breathe to it because it feels more awkward.
And uncomfortable.
So for the next 10 to 12 minutes,
I had a markedly more symmetrical team.
And I said,
that can't be a bad thing.
I didn't know the first thing about biomechanics at the time.
It just seemed evident to me aesthetically that anything that moved you straight
ahead was better than something that kept diverting you to the side.
And I,
you know,
I was just so gratified by the positive response to my first seat of the pants
experiment in stroke work that I thought I'm just going to carry on.
Uh,
and I did and it was,
it was not difficult,
you know,
and I had never been an assistant coach.
I had never taken a coaching course or anything even remotely related to sports
science or swimming or biomechanics or any of that.
Uh,
but I really trusted my aesthetic judgment.
I trusted that what looked good was good.
And I had,
I had an example of that.
I had a four lane pool and there was a hierarchy where the fast swimmers were in
lane one and the slow swimmers are in lane four.
And as I cast my eye across the pool,
the swimmers in lane one,
the fast swimmers looked more taller in the water.
They look longer as they stroked and they were markedly smoother.
And the swimmers in lane four were shorter and more choppy and more rough.
And I thought,
I'm just going to experiment with,
with them and try different things to see if I can make them look more like the
swimmers in lane one.
And uh,
another interesting thing happened when I started engaging with them and as I
said,
the coaching I got was all ready go coaching where the coach would give you a
set that lasted 30 minutes and then just sit and watch you.
But when I was,
when I was working with them on technique,
I,
I was engaging with them in a much more intimate manner.
Uh,
and I pretty quickly noticed that there was another difference between movement
form,
between quality of form,
uh,
and speed,
which was that kings point was a little bit different from a lot of colleges and
that there were no athletic scholarships.
Uh,
and so your reason for swimming came down to you.
Got,
you got excused from an unwelcome unpleasant duties like lake cleaning out the
latrine and marching and reviews and stuff like that during the,
during the length of the season,
uh,
or,
or you really wanted to swim.
Uh,
and I,
I,
so there was a big overlap between want to swim,
uh,
and good form and fast faster swimming in lane one and escapism and port form,
and uh,
and slow times in lane four.
So,
uh,
you know,
then I,
it was a matter of how to engage them as well.
And I found that these,
you know,
these tech,
the technique challenges that I was giving them in the little puzzles to solve
and so on,
uh,
brought out in them a certain zest for the workouts that had not been there
before.
So
I'm really curious to know the first,
uh,
where,
what would later become total immersion kind of entered the picture.
And I want to just make a couple of footnotes because it's related to a number
of things.
You said,
for instance,
the perhaps very,
uh,
in retrospect,
it's sensible and obvious advice to,
for instance,
do what I do now,
which is breathe every third stroke,
which means I'm going right,
left,
right,
uh,
in a very symmetrical way.
That's,
you know,
one,
one of the points that you,
you mentioned,
and then,
uh,
the,
the importance of a,
and this is something that I think applies to just about everything and just
about,
not everything but just about everything.
And that is when you get in the pool,
then I remember this,
this had a huge impact on me and I still have that very initial total immersion
book somewhere.
Um,
it's,
it got wet a lot.
So,
uh,
it's,
it's not in pristine condition,
but the idea that you are,
say,
getting in the pool to practice,
not to do a workout.
And at least in the beginning,
the idea that if it feels like a workout,
you're not doing it correctly,
was really difficult for me to first accept because I'm used to,
or at least at that point in physical training,
I thought that your results worry direct.
Uh,
output from an input,
which was effort.
Right?
And it was a huge mental shift for me to gauge my practice,
the quality of the success of a practice based on how little effort I expended
during say,
30 minutes in the pool.
Uh,
it was just,
it was a huge shift for me.
And I think that applies to producing quality in many,
many different areas,
at least in my experience.
Uh,
uh,
somewhat counter intuitively.
So w when did the,
uh,
sort of the,
the,
the bones of what would later
become a total immersion start to coalesce or start to appear?
Well,
let the powerful impact of working on technique and I'm not neglecting
conditioning whatsoever.
I,
my swimmers were very well conditioned everywhere I coached.
Um,
but the conditioning was always subordinate to the form.
In other words,
I would stop a sad if I wasn't satisfied with the form.
They might be swimming fast,
they might be swimming their hearts out.
But if I was not satisfied with the form,
I would stop the set,
redirect and restart the set and say,
you must maintain your form.
Um,
the,
the beginning of my conviction that that was,
that was an absolute,
that swimming success is based on superior form.
Uh,
came that first season at at kings point.
Um,
I had,
I had swim in that conference for four years.
I swam for Saint John's university and we were,
we swam against King's point for four years.
We swam in the conference championship,
uh,
each year.
And I took,
I took my team after doing all this technique work and radically reshaping their
strokes,
I have to say,
um,
to,
to the conference championship,
uh,
in,
at the,
at the end of the season.
And we just set the place on fire.
I just could not,
you know,
even having coached them the whole season,
I just was,
my mind was kind of boggled by,
by the times they swam simply because nothing in my experience prepared me to
see swimmers improve that much in swim that fast compared to the previous year.
Um,
I'll give you one example.
Sort of the premier event in college.
Swimming is the four by 100 freestyle relay.
It's always the final event in the,
in a collegiate championship meet.
And as for is for swimmers,
each swimming 100 yards or 100 meters.
Um,
and in the four years that I was in the conference,
the conference record for that event,
uh,
improved from three 25 to three 23 and as it happened,
I was fortunate that the,
when I was a senior,
uh,
the record of three 23.8 was set by my,
by,
by kings point relay.
So I inherited the championship and record holding relay.
Well,
they,
they came back my first year of coaching and went three 16
and one in one night.
They improve seven seconds.
What had,
you know what it improves two seconds in four years.
Uh,
and everybody's jaws were hanging around the pool and I realized,
oh my goodness,
what have I brought?
I had never done anything that you,
you know,
would suggest distinction of any sort in my life
prior to that night.
What would you do you recall the year on that?
Yeah.
That was march of 1973 and I was,
I was still 21 years old for goodness sakes.
I was the youngest coach in the Ncaa and now you ended up producing,
uh,
and,
and I want to sort of qualify my earlier statement,
also 24 national club and college champions,
right.
If I'm getting my facts straight.
So I don't want to imply that conditioning isn't a piece of,
uh,
successfully coaching a competitive team,
certainly,
but that it's a necessary but not sufficient.
Right?
I mean,
to produce the improvement that you did in the relay,
you can't just have them train harder,
uh,
or expend more calories in the pool.
It was a,
it was a technical improvement and I think that,
right,
right.
There's no way any change in conditioning.
Anything I could've done in workouts could have produced that improvement.
No way at all.
No.
Tell me,
tell me about bill boomer.
Uh,
we're,
where did,
where did bill into the picture and what effect did he have?
So I actually met bill,
Bill Ruh 1988,
and I,
I was just ready to step away from coaching.
I had gotten burned out.
Uh,
I still love coaching.
I love teaching,
but I was,
I had gotten a little burned out on dealing with parents.
Um,
and before,
before we,
before we just gloss over that.
So
can you give us an example?
Like what type of stuff burned you out with parents?
Yeah.
Well,
um,
there was one time where I had these two really sensational 12 year old boys.
Uh,
and um,
when I had really good swimmers I would,
I would make things a little more challenging for them.
I didn't want it to come too easily because at,
at age 12,
when you're a dominance,
when swimmer,
you're not used to being challenged.
So we got to our season,
uh,
our,
our net,
our state age group championships and I said to the,
to the 12 year old boys,
out of the eight events,
you're going to swim,
you can choose six,
but I'm going to choose to.
And they both knew what it would be.
It was going to be that they were both going to swim breaststroke events cause
that was their weakest event.
And I,
I wanted them to have at least one or two races where they really had to race,
uh,
and not just race each other.
Um,
and,
uh,
one,
one s one of the boys,
the parents came to me and complained bitterly about my forcing their son to do
that.
He had no problem with it.
He didn't,
he didn't have an objection or had not raised an objection,
but because it was going to hurt his chances of winning the high point.
And,
uh,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm thinking about his long term development,
not whether he wins the trophy at age 12 or,
and in the end,
the other boy who's who,
who,
who his parents were fully supportive,
he and his parents were fully supportive and he swam the restaurant events and I
decided it wasn't worth fighting that battle that if it was that important,
I'd let him not swim breaststroke,
but the other boys swam the breast stroke and ended up winning the high point
award.
You burning out because of overzealous,
uh,
or maybe overinvolved over vocal parents.
Yeah.
They had just lost their sense of perspective and in it and bill boomer,
uh,
came,
came into the,
came into the picture around that time.
Yeah.
So I'm,
I'm 37 years old and I had more money in the bank.
I,
you know,
I also had a 14 year old daughter who was,
I was thinking,
Oh,
I've got college costs coming up and you know,
coaching just didn't pay well.
I was one of the most successful,
uh,
most respected coaches in,
in the United States is in the age group ranks.
Uh,
and I,
I had never earned more than $15,000,
uh,
in a season and a had no money in the bank.
So I just decided I was going to cast about and see what other,
what else.
I'm my,
my native abilities might allow me to do that,
my pay better.
Uh,
and,
um,
so,
but I still wanted to coach.
I still want it to be,
keep my hand in it.
Uh,
I went,
I was invited to the American swimming coaches association.
Worldclinic it's,
it's the top,
um,
coaching clinic in the world.
And I was invited to talk on,
on a topic related to age group swimming.
And then immediately after I finished my talk,
I was sitting in the back of the room,
sort of decompressing with some coaching friends and I had intended to go see
Randi Reese,
the a head coach of the University of Florida at the time and a guy who had
coached many Olympians and world record holders.
And by the way,
the brother of the Eddie Reese who's coach at University of Texas at Austin and,
and probably the most successful coach we have in the United States.
So I was going to go see Randi Reese and learn how to coach world record holders
and um,
and bill boomer and it completely unheralded on,
uh,
little known coach with a really unconventional approach to things.
He was a coach at the University of Rochester and Rochester,
New York.
And uh,
he got up and started speaking and he just,
right,
right from his opening sentences,
uh,
it blew my mind.
He was talking about things I had never heard and the most,
the thing that he said that has stuck with me ever since that I'll,
I'll,
I'll stay.
I'll quote two quotes it has,
but the first was he says the shape of the engine is more important than this.
I'm sorry.
The shape of the vessel is more important than the size of the engine and
swimming and every,
every coaching talk.
I had been to over the PR of the previous 16 Years of going to coaching clinics.
Everyone had been about engine building,
not a single talk about vessel shaping.
What do we really mean by this?
That.
Well,
boomer says that a human body moving through the water should be treated like
any vessel and should be designed to move through the water with his little
dragon is little turbulence as as possible and engine building referred to both
building the aerobic engine through through cardiovascular conditioning and
emphasizing how powerful the Poland cake is by doing what I call arms
department,
legs,
department training,
where you,
you tie your legs together,
you,
you know,
you put a boy between them and a band,
a band around them,
take them out of the picture and then to put a pair of big paddles on your hands
and,
and muscle your way up and down the pool with your arm muscles or you immobilize
your arms and,
and possibly put on thins for more,
more power and muscle your way up and down the pool.
And,
uh,
separating the arms from the legs and in training disintegrating,
the body in other words.
So,
so the two types of engine building is,
is really all that I had ever heard emphasized.
Uh,
and,
and that was the first thing.
And I'll come back with another anecdote later,
uh,
to tell you why this resonated with maybe,
but the other thing that he said,
uh,
was that,
um,
conditioning is something that happens to you while you build,
refine and imprint skills.
Uh,
and just the fact that,
you know,
you would first look at the skill component first,
look at the skill impact of any training set or a task you get.
Uh,
and that the metabolic component,
the conditioning component would be a factor of the difficulty of the skill
task.
Um,
as opposed to just say to say to the swimmer,
I want your heart rate above one 74,
uh,
you know,
for the next 20 minutes,
ready,
go.
And,
uh,
you know,
before,
before we keep moving ahead with the chronology,
I'd love to talk about your experience,
uh,
which I think was,
maybe it was just before this,
you could clarify when exactly it happened,
but the,
the break that you took from coaching,
can you tell us a bit about that experience when you started,
when you were testing other avenues for,
uh,
making a living?
Yeah,
it ended up being writing.
I had started doing just a little bit of writing B while I was still coaching.
I wrote one article for slimming world magazine and a few other things for
newsletters.
I always wrote a piece for our club newsletter,
you know,
from the coach's perspective.
Um,
and I,
I found,
I enjoyed communicating by writing and I thought I would try.
So,
uh,
my wife Alison,
I started a marketing communications,
very tiny little mom and pop agency called main street communications.
We lived on Main Street and Goshen,
New York and um,
and we wrote speeches and PR stuff and things like that for small businesses in
the area.
At the same time,
I started writing articles for,
for small local magazines.
And then I happened to go to my 20th,
three high school reunion.
Uh,
and one of my classmates was the editor of a magazine,
uh,
on corporate hedging on how multinational companies hedge,
their currency risk,
which was much greater in those days before the,
uh,
before the unification of the eurozone.
Uh,
they were all those currencies in Europe.
And so they were,
they were at great risk of,
of currency moves,
uh,
and interest rate risk and political risk and commodity risk,
all these forms of risks that you undertake.
And so I,
you know,
he said,
what are you doing?
I said,
well,
I'm doing a little bit of magazine writing.
He said,
why don't you send me a clip?
And he ended up giving me an assignment and I,
I,
you know,
I turned out I was pretty good at interviewing and distilling the information
and,
and writing about it even though I knew nothing about puts and calls and,
and all these hedging strategies.
And,
um,
so I ended up,
I earned my living primarily through writing about international corporate
finance,
which is kind of a crazy thing,
uh,
during,
during the time that I wasn't coaching.
Why did you come back to coaching?
Um,
well,
I,
you know,
I wasn't away from coaching very long.
I,
I actually,
uh,
was an assistant coach at west point with a responsibility to be the,
my portfolio was coaching technique for,
for everybody on the team.
My good friend,
Ray Bossy,
uh,
had just taken over as head coach and he asked me to help him make the
transition during his first year.
So I did,
that was 1988,
89 when I had started the writing and stuff.
Um,
and um,
I enjoy just working tech always had
enjoyed teaching technique.
And uh,
in 1988,
uh,
in August of 1988,
I resumed swimming.
I had knots woman 17 years since college.
And,
uh,
I saw that masters nationals,
we're going to be in buffalo not far from my house.
So I thought,
well,
I'll start swimming again and I'll go to that masters nationals and see how I
like it.
So the,
the,
the takeaways I got was that everybody seemed to be having great fun and I was
super impressed by the people in the 55 and over age groups,
how,
how fit they were and how fast they were a,
and I thought,
I want to be like them when I get to be that age.
So,
um,
so I was,
I was introduced to master swimming and I thought,
well,
if I,
if I coached these folks,
I probably won't have any parent problems.
And uh,
so the next summer I decided I was going to hold a summer camp,
the summer camps for kids where a common thing,
you know,
would like other sports.
There were week long and longer summer camps for different sports.
So summer camps are swimmers were pot were were something I knew well.
Uh,
and I thought I'd offer one for adults and a,
so I did 19 or June of 1989 at Colgate university in Hamilton,
New York.
I had the first ever total immersion camp.
Where did I get the name?
Total immersion because I didn't want to call it Terry Laughlin swung camp.
To me that was like calling it some guys swim camp.
I thought I needed a better,
a better name than just my name.
So I was,
I was reading a magazine one day and I came across an ad for Berlitz language
schools and they were offering what they call it,
total immersion language courses.
And I said,
that certainly works as well through swimming as it does for,
for language.
So I,
I chose that name and then waited about five years for a letter from their
lawyers telling me to cease and desist before I went to a lawyer and found it.
Oh,
I could,
I could trademark total immersion swimming,
which I,
I did finally.
Uh,
so I had total immersion swim camp,
uh,
in the summer of 89 and I had six swimmers the first week in nine.
The second I had,
uh,
I had an Olympic swimmer on 1948 Olympian from,
from Holland,
who was now a resident of Canada,
uh,
of an Ottawa,
and,
and came to the camp.
And,
uh,
so I,
I taught,
I taught those people what I had been teaching for 20 years or not 20 years,
but,
uh,
18 years,
17 years.
Um,
I what I had been teaching two age group swimmers because these people were all
very conversant with swimming.
A lot of them had swum when they were kids,
you know,
not to mention having an Olympian.
Uh,
and they were all very comfortable in the water and you know,
everything,
everything that I did work well with them and uh,
you know,
a cup,
a couple of them said I improved more in five days and I have in the last 10
years.
So that was something that
I found I enjoyed.
I found,
worked well with the,
with the people and I continued doing that for the next,
uh,
for the next several years.
But,
um,
I,
I all,
I had masters swimmers the first year and the third year I had my first
triathlete come,
come to one of these four stroke camps.
And first of all,
they were mainly interested in,
in freestyle,
not in the other three strokes.
And secondly,
when we finished a pool session,
we had two pull sessions a day,
one morning,
one afternoon.
And I,
I wanted them to rest up for the afternoon.
They would go out for a bike ride or run and come back,
all sweaty.
Uh,
so I wasn't thrilled.
but it,
the,
the proportion of triathletes grew so rapidly that by about the fourth or fifth
year,
it was 70% triathletes and we were doing just freestyle.
Now we're,
if we're going to f let's,
if you don't mind flash forward as you see you're forming total immersion,
you're developing and testing different methods.
If we look back at our experience that we shared in Hawaii with,
uh,
Sarah,
who was very much novice swimmer,
uncomfortable putting her face underwater,
right?
A mother of I think too at the time and for the Tim Ferriss experiment,
a TV show at the time,
we wanted to show,
demonstrate that it wasn't just an anomaly,
that I had learned to swim in this way and that in fact it could be replicated.
So we brought Sarah to Hawaii and uh,
I'm going to back into the technique,
but started with kind of coughing and having a lot of trouble really just
submerging her face to a few days later.
And keeping in mind that for those people who watch nonfiction TV or reality TV,
if it's actually reality TV,
which this was meaning,
it's not highly scripted.
We're actually capturing someone as they progress from zero to hopefully open
water swimmer.
There's a locker on the line,
you're putting it on,
you're really on the line.
And also you have audio issues.
You have camera reframing.
So you might think that with say Sarah,
we had four or five days of training,
but in reality we had a much,
a shortened period of time.
It was probably half of that time that we had to work.
Sure.
Very complicated and challenging instructional environment with all the,
all the technical people around and all the cameras and the reshoots and all of
that.
Yeah,
it really it.
But it worked.
And uh,
she ended up swimming in very deep water,
open water,
uh,
sinks,
swimming with both of us,
uh,
a breathing in freestyle stroke.
It was just tremendous.
But where do you take someone like a Sarah and begin?
We're,
where do you start?
Because I think this is where a lot of people who try to learn to swim and you
know,
they swallow their pride and go to the pool or find a coach where things go
sideways.
And certainly that was true for me.
Uh,
where do you start?
Do you start by getting into the deep end and,
and trying to learn how to breathe while you've swim?
Freestyle?
No,
no.
Very,
very small bits.
A very,
what I call mini skills in micro skills.
We always teach in a step by step fashion where each step leads naturally to the
next and as a scaffold,
uh,
for,
for the next step.
So,
so I meet Sarah,
uh,
at the,
at the pool,
uh,
on,
on Monday morning.
We began to shoot on Monday morning.
And,
uh,
we,
I said,
okay,
well,
let's see what you can do.
A,
and the cameras are rolling and tag.
Sarah Swims about six or eight strokes furiously,
just,
just flailing away,
uh,
with their head out of the water had had just whipping back and forth.
Uh,
and then she needs a breath.
Then what does she do?
She stopped.
She can't breathe and swim.
So she,
she had to stop and she did that a few times.
Uh,
and I,
I,
I knew,
you know,
I had a pretty good idea what I was going to say.
You probably recognize that from your own experience,
Tim.
Oh,
sure.
You know,
the way she was swimming and survival,
the drowning monkey technique,
right?
Well,
you know,
here,
I cited this statistic earlier of of only 2% of American adults can swim 400
meters nonstop,
only 30% consumed,
25 yards.
Just one,
you know,
one length of,
of your local local pool.
Uh,
only 30% can,
can swim one lap.
Don,
stop.
So that was you,
Tim.
As I recall,
your story was in a 20 yard pool and swimming about two thirds of the way the
way down and not being able to get past that two thirds,
two thirds points.
So it,
what is it?
It's an inability to breathe because you can't get air,
you can't carry on a,
but you can't just start in with breathing,
uh,
because there's,
there's a series of skills that you have to learn first.
So what did we have Sarah do first?
I'm doing a glide,
a very,
very simple glide with arms extended at shoulder with,
we call it superman.
It's superman.
Uh,
I,
this is instructing,
instructing Sarah to just glide to just,
um,
hang her head between her shoulders,
which is an,
it's an,
um,
it's a non instinctive thing,
but it's exceptionally important.
In fact,
it's,
it's counterintuitive.
What was and snake was to hold her head up to,
to um,
avoid choking.
And I here,
I was telling her,
so I want you to hang your head in the water.
I want you to let it go.
Uh,
and she discovered when she,
she let her head hanging the water that she could glide and her body didn't sink
and she could just glide effortlessly,
maybe five or six yards.
And that's kind of that,
that's a life changing experience for someone who's always felt that they,
they were sinker.
Right?
Well,
you're showing the,
uh,
the how,
the shape of the vessel and I had the hydrodynamics
exactly changes the whole game where we in fact were shaping the vessel to too,
so that she could glide five or six yards without any effort so that she could
just look down and see the pool bottom passing under her without her doing
anything.
And at the same time feel this,
uh,
incredible sense of support,
almost weightlessness from the water.
And I just want to highlight something here or a few things.
The first is that this is happening in,
let's call it four feet of water,
right?
It's just Sarah can stand up at any time if she wants to.
So it's removing that fear factor a second.
She's not kicking,
she's not pulling with her hands.
She simply gliding,
right?
So you're driving and shaping the vessel.
So you're isolating that prerequisite,
a skill or component that leads to the rest.
And one thing that really struck me,
this is true in my experience with all really,
really profound instruction,
whether it's music or say recently for me,
tennis with a coach named Lorenzo Beltrami who just blew my mind with teaching
me how to serve properly.
Uh,
and I just want to draw a parallel,
if you don't mind the digression because,
or Josh Waitzkin has been on this podcast and how he teaches chess,
which is very much what you would not expect.
And what you find is that almost by definition,
really profound instruction is very different from what you would expect because
what you expect gets very mediocre results.
Uh,
and,
and for instance,
you know,
Josh starts with,
and I think we'll come back to this,
but first principles,
right?
He wants,
he wants someone to understand the principles of chess in this case.
And for those people that don't know the name,
he was the basis for the book and the movie searching for Bobby Fischer.
And he'll take all of the pieces off the chess board and start with a,
uh,
I think it's just king versus king and pawn to teach very,
very flexible principles that then apply to the rest of the games.
So he'll start with the end game in order to demonstrate those principles.
Uh,
but perhaps a more direct parallel would be Lorenzo,
when he was teaching me,
I'd never been able to serve in tennis or really,
I never had learned how to play tennis period.
But what he started me with is he said,
all right,
you're going to hold the tennis ball in your left hand and you want your hand
sideways.
All right,
so that,
uh,
so that you're not whipping the ball backwards and I want you to just practice
throwing the ball up and having it land a few inches in front of your feet.
That's all I want you to do.
So I'm just throwing the tennis ball up,
having it land in front of my feet so that I'm not throwing it behind me or too
far ahead of meeting cause okay,
great.
Actually,
if I take it back,
that was step two.
Step one was practice lightly and loosely throwing a tennis ball over the net,
just like a,
just like a soft baseball throw.
Second was with my left hand throwing the ball up and having it land in front of
me,
just a few inches in front of my foot.
Then the next step was throwing the first ball up and then trying to hit it
within the tennis ball that I'm throwing with my rear hand.
And then literally he just said,
okay,
here's a tennis racket,
try to hit the tennis ball and boom right into the zone on the other side of the
net.
And it just was one of those moments.
And that just made my head kind of explode,
which was also the case with total immersion.
And with this logical progression,
that's sort of what I want to underscore is that you're building on each of
these skills.
Uh,
and it just gets me so excited when people ask me,
know,
why are you trying to learn the Gamelan from Indonesia?
Why are you trying to learn this or that?
It's these Aha moments where you do something for say,
Sarah and she goes,
Holy Shit,
for lack of a better,
more elegant way to put it,
I could actually do this.
Uh,
and um,
see you have Sarah gliding.
What are some of the other important initial s,
uh,
skills or exercises that you layer on top of that?
Well.
Um,
one of the things that,
that you have written in your,
you know,
when you,
when you write about metal learning,
one of the principles that you have cited for that is avoid error points.
Right.
And as soon as I,
soon as I read that,
I recognized,
oh yeah we did that.
You know,
Tim,
Tim's got it.
And what are the two points and you know,
from your experience,
what are the two hour points were swimmers.
Oh boy.
You know what,
I'm a funder.
I'm caught on the spot.
I would say,
well number one is,
is just fear of not being able to touch the bottom.
Uh,
at least for me,
I'll just name and for those people who are wondering what I mean.
So if we're looking at failure points,
I can,
I can tell you,
is it to,
you decided when you wrote,
when you wrote about it kicking and breathing,
kicking and breathing,
right.
King and breathing.
Cause every,
every time somebody handed you a kickboard is you said your feet just slice
through the water,
like razor blades and you went nowhere.
Yeah.
That's everybody's experience.
Nobody can propel on a kickboard except really people who are already really
good swimmers.
Yeah.
So,
so that's a totally useless tool to learn to swim.
But everybody,
what did they do?
What does everybody do?
They hand you a kickboard to try to strengthen your legs so your legs won't
sink.
That's not the problem you're having.
Weak legs is not the problem.
So the problem,
the first problem we solved with Sarah was fear of fear of sinking.
Um,
and we took out the breathing component.
We said we're going to add that later when,
when you are ready,
when you have,
when you have a,
um,
a platform of skills so that you can control something about how you breathe.
And we'll introduce that.
And you know,
we're,
we're going to not even make kicking part of it at all,
but um,
teach you as you have written Tim,
to have the legs draft behind the upper body.
Um,
so,
so we had her do exactly that with,
with the superman glide,
which is just let out a pearl size string of bubbles so that you're not holding
your breath a and don't cake.
Press your legs lightly together and just feel your body body gliding.
That was,
that was step one.
The second step was to teach her to shape her body for the most hydrodynamic
position in the crawl stroke and the most hydrodynamic position,
the one where you experienced the least drag,
uh,
is the fully extended position.
So when you've reached forward with one arm and,
and press back with the other arm and you're fully extended and rotated just a
little bit off your stomach.
So we call that scape position because it brings to mind,
or I would like to bring to mind the blade of a speed skate and a to shape your
body to be as long and sleek and balanced as,
as it as it can be.
Um,
and so what,
what we did there was the superman glide does not occur in freestyle.
So we just use that to get her comfortable in the water,
to give her a sense that she had control of her body position.
Very important to feel that you're in control.
And then,
and then the very next step was to put her in the most hydrodynamic position.
So we started with the most important moment in the stroke and,
and let her become very,
very familiar with all the fine details of that moment.
Where should your hand be a year extended hand be?
It should be in a particular place.
It should be below your body,
uh,
and it should be on,
on a track with the whole right side of your body.
If it's your right arm,
uh,
and your left shoulder should be barely above the surface,
you should be looking straight down.
You should be a kicking very,
very minimally.
And so we taught her that position.
I would say we spent a good part of an entire pool session just,
uh,
letting salary Sarah become familiar with and in control of that,
that position.
No,
definitely.
And I did a couple of things that that come to mind that I also want to bring up
that were particularly helpful for me.
Number one was having a,
and I'm very quantified in sense that I like to have a number I can use for
tracking improvement,
but when you're just learning how to swim,
looking at say lapse speed is,
is is going to encourage bad behavior,
right?
It's going to,
again,
courage,
at least in me,
the thrashing and overexertion that we want to have wood.
But the looking at the uh,
sort of stroke count per length ended up being really helpful for me.
So for instance,
you know,
I went from in about four workouts a,
this is again by myself,
just self coaching with the book,
more than 25 strokes per 20 yard length to an average of around 11 strokes.
Uh,
so I had,
I had doubled my sort of efficiency.
Right.
And I'll just run through a couple of quick notes that I have here.
So the first is more of a Metacomet,
which is people think of swimming and I thought of swimming as something you do
on top of the water.
Uh,
and I'll just list a few of these and then we can,
we can dig into dig into them,
but whereas in fact your body's denser that or very often denser than water,
you're going to be mostly submerged.
So if you think of freestyle is as having say 90%,
you could give you probably more accurate percentage,
but like 90% of your body underwater.
Then when you are swimming,
say freestyle,
your body is going to be mostly underwater.
Uh,
and just accepting that removes a huge fear factor because if you're accustomed
to thinking,
I have to swim in order to breathe,
I have to keep my body on top of the water.
You're on a suicide mission,
it's just not going to work.
The physics don't provide for it,
you will always win that battle.
Yeah,
gravity is always going to win.
So when you would,
when you're taught from the very outset or the expectations set,
all right,
your body is going to be 95,
90,
95% underwater.
And your goal and let's start by kicking off a wall and four feet of water is to
glide from say sort of fuselage,
right to fuselage left,
right?
So if we,
if we think of freestyle,
not as swimming on your stomach but from alternating from one extended position
to the other,
just like you would go from say right speed skate to left speed skate like you
were mentioning earlier and that extended position,
uh,
things change really quickly.
And uh,
thinking of these are just a couple of the counterintuitive things on a mention
for people that really helped me.
Another was focusing on driving your arm through the water as opposed to polling
in order to encourage that position.
Uh,
the looking straight down,
which you mentioned also I think very counterintuitive for folks and having your
arm when you are in that fully extended position,
a good deal underwater,
uh,
not on top of the water.
And what that does is helps to apply water pressure on the arm and raise the
legs.
Right?
So my issue
or what I thought was my,
I call that the trim tab effect.
So shit that the trim tabs on an air airplane,
our airplane work to raise or lower the nose.
If you have something in front hydrodynamics and arrogant Amex or work exactly
the same.
And if you have something in front of the vessel that is angled down,
it's going to lift the rear.
And that's so the arm is acting as a trim tab for your body and effortlessly
lifting your legs to the surface,
meaning,
uh,
two,
two really important things.
Uh,
one is you save on the energy of caking and the second is you save a huge amount
of turbulence and drag.
So just,
you know,
using the arm in that way,
who would ever think that that's more important than pushing water back.
What are some of the,
the drills or exercises that you found most helpful for translating or
translating to most of the components you want to emphasize to one exercise?
So one that I've found just really,
really tremendously helpful was hand swapping.
Uh,
so if you could talk to perhaps you a front quadrant swimming a little bit,
but the idea that,
you know,
what,
when in doubt,
if I feel like I'm,
I'm getting a little panicky or getting tired or whatever it might be,
I think of,
of hand swapping.
Uh,
could you,
could you describe what that means for people?
Sure.
So our innate,
um,
primal instinct when we start swimming as to windmill,
the arms heedlessly just,
just turn away with the arms,
meaning generally the arms are going to be a 180 degrees apart,
um,
or,
or close to it.
And not only are you not creating much propulsion by windmilling your arms,
you're also creating a whole lot of drag.
Um,
that's a sort of a fatal prescription for getting anywhere.
And so we always have prioritize what we call vessel shaping or shaping,
shaping your humans swimming body to minimize drag during all moments in the
stroke.
And so the first thing you can do to minimize drag is use your arm to lengthen
your body.
The longer the body is,
the less the less drag there is.
And then you need to think a little bit about stroke timing in,
in terms of that,
because you want to keep the body long for a bit more of the recovery.
The recovery is when you bring in your arm forward.
Um,
so essentially we are teaching people to leave the extended arm forward until
the other arm is just about to re enter the water after completing and three
covering and uh,
and not simply to leave it there,
but to hold your place to,
uh,
to actively use your hand,
to hold your place because you're going to spear the other hand.
Once you,
once you enter the water,
you're going to spirit past your grip and use,
uh,
use power from the high side of the body to move passenger Grep.
So instead of propelling with just your arm and shoulder muscles,
you're propelling with your whole body.
So this is,
I mean,
we're really deconstructing in a way is progressive mastery of a given skill.
It would seem to me,
and you I know are a big fan of a book titled Mastery by George Leonard.
Right.
Can you tell us about how you,
how you found that book and your experience in,
in reading it?
I'd like to dig into it just a little bit because I think it's widely
applicable.
Yeah.
Sometime in the 1990s,
uh,
somebody,
someone brought to my attention,
a magazine article he had,
he had written for I believe,
Esquire,
uh,
the in,
in the late eighties,
and it was more reprints where request of that article then any other article
they would,
they had ever printed in it.
And,
uh,
it was about mastery.
And the story George was telling was that of taking up I kido at age 47 very
advanced age and then becoming the latest starter ever to reach the,
to reach the master teacher level.
And I Kido,
uh,
and,
and how did he manage,
uh,
manage to accomplish that?
And it was,
it was just a set of,
um,
a set of prescriptions or principals,
uh,
for,
for attaining mastery.
And,
and,
you know,
the,
the essential idea of,
of this,
this,
that life is not designed to make things easy for us,
but to present us with challenges that help us grow.
Uh,
and that we should embrace these challenges.
And,
uh,
and you know,
something you've done for many years,
Tim,
um,
that we should embrace these challenges.
And if we apply behaviors,
we're going to,
we're going to experience a lot more success.
And,
and so the behaviors he cited were,
first of all,
always be focused on improving the skill itself.
And anytime you are doing it,
you're focused on improving the skill,
uh,
the,
the amount of time you spend,
what your heart rate is or any of that is secondary to doing things that improve
the scale.
Uh,
a second is to focus on weak points.
don't focus on your strengths.
A third,
and I really love this one,
this one is my favorite is to love the plateau a in anything we learn.
Uh,
we initially as we're working our way through the most basic and easiest skills
we learned pretty rapidly.
And then things start to slow down and then things may slow down to the point
where you only experience a breakthrough every six to 12 months or so.
And George George Leonard wrote that,
uh,
when you practice with,
with a guided by the principles of mastery,
there is always positive change taking place at the cellular level,
below your threshold of awareness.
And that periodically this change consolidates into a thrilling leap forward,
which was very much my own experience.
I proved it to myself with my own experience where by the time I had been,
by the time I had been swimming 50 years,
in other words,
I'm in my mid sixties and I've,
I've really been swimming 50 years,
maybe even a,
uh,
you know,
51 52 years.
I was still learning things that thrilled me.
I was still getting insights about my own stroke that weren't literally
thrilling and they were coming at really,
really long intervals.
And so having read George Leonard,
you know,
long before I was in my sixties,
I was really prepared for that eventuality.
Can you teach people to love the plateau or are there ingredients that help
people to persist through a plateau?
Uh,
what,
what and,
and if so,
what are they?
Because I think that this is such a common quitting point for a lot of people
where they,
they are,
uh,
myself included.
I'm not immune to this.
Uh,
we'll get the sort of the,
the sugar high of the initial Aha moments and making rapid progress in rapid
experiencing rapid change.
And then,
oh,
now it's very,
very incremental.
Now it's barely perceptible and I feel like I'm not making progress or even
backsliding.
How,
how do you,
how would you help someone to persist through plateau,
that plateau and I suppose learned to love it
if possible.
Yeah.
Well I think there's a couple of things now.
I think one of the things you want to do is give,
give them enough of the right sort of information about the foundations of
excellence in what they have taken up a that they become curious to learn more.
So,
so first you need to stimulate their curiosity and eventually you get to what I
hope for,
you know,
for everyone I teach I hope becomes passionate curiosity,
uh,
where you know,
so you move from curiosity to being really intrigued to wanting to really solve
this,
to becoming passionate about it.
Uh,
and it's,
it's that hierarchy.
You've got to love what you're doing.
Um,
and they're,
you know,
there's,
there's a a good deal,
there's a good deal of evidence about what causes people to love what they're
doing.
And one of the most important is,
is simply the goal of enjoying enjoy it.
Today,
if I'm going to work out for an hour,
my goal is to enjoy my,
my hour of workout.
At the beginning of the year.
Uh,
health clubs all oversee,
see a flock of people signing up and they sign up far more people than they can
actually serve because they know that about two thirds of them are going to not
use their membership.
Uh,
they're gonna,
you know,
they're going to start out with all the fire and then lose it and stop going to
the gym.
And uh,
there there's been,
there's been a pretty authoritative study that showed the main difference
between the people who continued using their membership.
And those who do not was that those who we use stop using their membership had
in mind some,
some benefit they might receive in six months time while the people who use
their membership and stayed with it.
Uh,
just enjoyed going to the gym every day.
They did things that brought them pleasure,
uh,
in the moment.
So I think pleasure in the moment.
This is really important.
And the other thing is you've got to be really engaged with it.
And it's,
if I see people on the aerobic equipment at,
at my gym,
what do I see?
Well,
some of them are reading books and disassociating from what they're doing and
others are really paying attention to what they're doing.
They may be using an elliptical machine or a or running treadmill or something
for the umpteenth time,
but there's still finding details about how they use that machine,
uh,
that are worth their attention.
So what,
uh,
what might some of those details be?
And I'll,
I'll add a few that I found helpful,
uh,
for
persisting in the face of a potential,
say,
technical plateau,
right?
Or even strength plateau for instance,
in the case of strength training.
So a few things that,
that help me to continue.
Number one is in the case of swimming,
recognizing the sort of beneficial mental shift and uh,
emotional psychological shift that takes place in me.
Even if I am not a swimming more laps or improving times,
my state coming out of the pool is almost always better than it was going into
the pool.
I just feel better.
And so that has benefits even if I'm not say,
developing towards being a top competitive swimmer.
Uh,
the second,
and this is true for me in almost everything,
but I have measurables.
Uh,
so,
and it doesn't mean that I'm tracking my measurables from workout to workout,
but it gives me,
I found,
I find the act of counting very meditative.
Uh,
so the fact that I have,
for instance,
in weight training,
usually there's a cadence.
Let's say it's two seconds up,
four seconds down or yesterday I did a workout where I was doing five seconds
up,
five seconds down.
So there's a,
there's a,
there's a tempo counting and then there's a repetition counting.
And then I'm logging the sets and I find for whatever reason that increases my
adherence to something.
If I have a,
a quantification.
In the case of swimming,
I have the one,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three of breathing on alternate sides.
And then I also have the strokes per length,
uh,
that I can focus on or the hand swapping drill.
And,
uh,
the,
the last that comes to mind is specifically as it relates to swimming because
there is,
I think,
still a tiny part of me in the back of my head that is afraid of drowning.
I mean,
there's,
there's a tiny part that still has the fear accumulated over 30 years.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I'm,
I'm comfortable in the water,
but what I think helps me to continue to want to go back to the pool is always
doing less than what I feel capable of doing,
which is very much the opposite of what I've done almost every,
in almost every other place,
not everywhere,
but in the case of swimming,
there are a few other places,
uh,
where you have fine motor skill.
Uh,
tennis also true,
doing less than I feel is possible.
So in other words,
stopping before my technique really deteriorates.
Sam,
how long do you usually swim?
I swim for very short periods of time.
Uh,
I would say,
uh,
typically less than 45 minutes.
Very good.
That's what I,
that's what I would recommend to most people.
Okay,
got it.
Yeah,
I mean,
I would say very often I'll go in and I'll do 20 to 30 minutes.
It's not,
it's not a,
it's not a long workout.
And I try not to view it as a workout.
It's really in a practice of moving meditation for me.
Uh,
and if I want to smash my body in some type of other training,
that's fine.
But in the pool,
I view it more as a
practice in elegance and efficiency to the,
to the greatest extent possible.
You're moving through a fluid,
what could be better than flow in your on moment.
Right,
right.
Uh,
now I,
you know,
there's,
uh,
I see,
I took a note here and I don't know the story,
so I'll bring it up.
This is,
it looks like from 2000 and,
uh,
the story of Phil Cruz.
Uh,
can you tell me who fill cruises and what happened in 2000?
Yeah.
Uh,
I think,
I think I,
maybe 1999,
I did a workshop in Chapel Hill.
We had maybe 20,
20 a 10 days.
Um,
and,
uh,
we had one in particular who was the most challenged student that I had yet
seen.
Um,
he did what Sarah did,
uh,
during our first video taping,
thrashed about five strokes and stood up to breathe.
And,
and that was it.
Uh,
and by the end of the two day workshop on Sunday afternoon,
it was a triumph for him to,
to not navigate one length of the pool continuously was with a hybrid between a,
between drilling and swimming.
It wasn't even the whole stroke.
Um,
so fast forward,
uh,
18 months and I'm teaching what we call a Kaizen camp,
in Florida.
And,
uh,
it's a four stroke camp if you want to learn all four strokes and being
freestyle,
backstroke,
breaststroke,
butterfly had and butterfly.
Correct.
And,
um,
they didn't have to do four strokes,
but they can do any number of the four that they wanted.
Uh,
and we videotaped everybody in the first session to get them before I'll be four
picture,
um,
any,
any of the strokes that you wanted.
And while we were videotaping freestyle,
uh,
one of these,
one of these camp participants when the most
unbelievably beautiful freestyle at the,
at the level of our best coaches,
just that,
that sort of grace and fluency and ease.
Um,
and uh,
so,
uh,
you know,
after,
after word I said a where did you learn that?
And he said from you if he came,
he came clear that he was the person who had attended,
you know,
he'd been at that at a such a,
such a challenge when we're 18 months earlier in Chapel Hill.
And not only that,
but,
uh,
he was a soybean farmer.
Um,
he,
he had previously worked in a management position and then became a gentleman
farmer after,
after retiring from that.
But he farmed soybeans and
coastal North Carolina and he was 25 miles from the nearest pool.
So in that intervening 18 months,
I mean,
everybody we teach improves.
Okay.
So I'm not,
that's not the standard,
it's just I,
my mind was blown by the degree to which he improved.
And then I found out he did it entirely on his own.
He had no other resources or help or anything.
And you know,
it was just driving himself to the YMC 25 miles away and did it in nine and in,
in a year and a half on his own.
And I became what that stimulated in me.
It was a curiosity when shell someone shows absolutely no knack for something,
how do they get that good?
That was that,
that was something that really intrigued.
So what was the,
what were the,
what were the components?
What were,
what went into his practice?
What did he do,
do you think that led to that degree of improvement?
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I'd say first of all,
not everybody is as good as he is or as you were at self coaching.
Um,
so he started out,
it did start it out with some coaching,
but it was just two days of coaching and then 18 months on his own.
Um,
so I suppose he probably had probably pretty,
pretty well acquainted with a spotty for whatever reason.
Um,
that's,
that's one thing.
But the second thing is he,
I think he probably just faithfully followed through on practicing the drills
very patiently,
very attentively,
uh,
until he really understood them and constantly refined his,
his form and the drills and then,
and then taking whatever he learned from the drills and putting it into,
into whole stroke practices.
He probably gave not a,
not a moment's thought to speed or how far he was swimming.
I'll bet he did what you did Tim,
which was a to only practice for as long as he felt the practice was fruitful.
The other were a,
I mean a handful of things that I think in any practice for me at least help
with self coaching.
Uh,
the,
the first would be whenever possible having a,
uh,
as,
as they would say in the startup world,
a key performance indicator.
So what is the number that you are trying to improve week on week?
And uh,
there's,
there's actually a very famous,
for lack of,
or to keep it simple,
I'll say a startup incubator called y Combinator nicknamed YC based in Silicon
Valley that can be thought of as the Harvard meets seal team six of,
of,
of startup training.
And they bring in a very,
very small percentage of people who apply and work into the ground 24,
seven or these people don't really need help to do that.
They'll do it on their own and at the end they have a business that they pitch
to investors and so on.
And during that period,
uh,
they almost all choose a KPI key performance indicator.
And the goal is to say improve at 10% week on week.
So for me,
in swimming,
I decided early on with the help of,
of total immersion in book form.
And then later I got the DVDs was the stroke count,
the number of strokes per lap.
And that was my,
that was my true north.
Like anything that I did that hurt that I ended up either fixing or discarding
and anything I did that improved that I would continue practicing.
And
then on top of that,
I would test all of these various drills and realized for myself that the hand
swapping drill,
not saying it's true for everyone,
but in my case focusing on that front quadrant swimming and the hand swapping
was what most quickly returned me to a very,
uh,
optimal for me and my skill level,
stroke per lap,
if that made sense.
Uh,
and then last,
and this is actually much easier now at the time go pro,
uh,
either didn't exist or was very,
very early and kind of a version one,
the one,
uh,
type technology,
but having some means of video observation or correction I just think is so
incredibly helpful.
And I've used that in a swimming to a lesser extent,
but only when we had the gear in Hawaii to do so.
And of course in my head,
I've been practicing total immersion for a while.
At that point I was like,
okay,
you know,
I,
I've,
I feel like my,
my technique's pretty good.
And then you see it on camera and you just want to cringe.
Uh,
and uh,
that was also true when I was in Argentina in 2004,
2005 and ended up competing in tango and I mean,
I ended up going to the world championships and making it to the semifinals,
but about,
I would say three months prior to that,
I remember I was two or three months into practicing tango.
Felt like I had really made a lot of progress.
I had been,
uh,
taking video of different instructors,
different dancers.
I'd been cataloguing technique.
I'd been writing down my specific goals for each as I viewed it practice
session,
slash,
workout.
And then I would have one or two things each day that I would work on in the
uncontrolled environment of a Milonga,
which is a dance hall.
So I thought I was not hot shit,
but I thought that I was really on my road to being a fantastic dancer.
And then I remember I went and I bought a video camera.
This is on Avine,
the Florida in we know,
say it is,
Eh,
where they have a lot of electronic store.
So I bought this camera,
took it to practice,
had somebody record me dancing with this woman and it was horrible.
It looked what,
what I was doing in my head and what I was doing on the camera were so different
that they would have been unrest.
I mean,
you would never have paired my video to what I would have described myself
doing.
And that is what allowed me though,
that sort of harsh reality is what allowed me to really,
really,
really improve after that point.
Are there any other types of practice,
uh,
or types of self talk?
Uh,
any types of,
uh,
planning or journaling or anything that you have seen helpful,
or that you've observed in people who self coach?
Well,
because I think this is such an important skill.
If you're trying to get,
if you want to be an autodidact and most of the time,
even if you have access to good coaches,
you will be without a coach.
Uh,
you know,
what are,
what are some of the things that you've seen a contribute to good self coaching?
Um,
yes,
a video,
very,
very important tool,
very helpful tool for anything more movement Orient.
There has never been a time that I have them videotape that I was satisfied with
what I saw to this day.
Um,
but you know,
if I can cite my own experience,
um,
I,
because I had been my own total immersion coach all along.
Um,
I,
I got into,
you know,
once I,
I have to step back a little bit and talk about how my mind was open to how,
how much,
how much potential improvement was available to me that I had not realized that
all,
uh,
going back to bill boomer,
after I heard him talk at that clinic,
I,
I drove up to Rochester to watch him coach and see him put into practice the
things he talked about and pick his brain.
Um,
and one of the things that he talked about was that the keystone skill of
swimming was balanced.
Now,
I had never even heard of balance as a skill of swimming.
And he was saying it was the keystone to efficiency.
Uh,
so he talked about balance during the,
during the clinic thing.
And,
uh,
then when I went up,
I said,
Bill,
would you teach me something about balance?
So he,
he taught me a drill that he called pressing the bully or print pressing the t,
excuse me.
Um,
he called it pressing the t where you would have your arms at your sides and be
flood or kicking with your head in line with your spine and lean on your chest
as you do.
So.
So I did that.
And I had spent 25 years thinking I had the misfortune to be born with heavy
legs.
It's a bad thing as a swimmer to be born with heavy legs.
And I spent a quarter century thinking I was doomed.
Yeah.
Um,
and in 10 seconds doing this drill at that,
that whole concept was exploded because my legs were light.
And I never realized that I could,
you know,
I had the power to do something to change that.
Can you explain the drill one more time please?
Yeah,
yeah.
We,
we,
uh,
we teach it today.
We call it torpedo boat.
We do it without the flutter kick butt.
But essentially you put your arms at your sides and you glide with your head in
line with your spine kicking gently and,
and lean a little bit on your chest.
And what you feel is your hips and legs become lighter.
They're,
they're lifted by the,
by a lever effect.
You,
you know,
a lever effect of leaning.
What's the most buoyant part of your body is your chest.
You've got a,
you've got about you,
you,
you've got,
um,
a,
uh,
s your lungs in there that holds six liters of air.
That's the most buoyant part of the body.
Um,
and um,
so when you lean,
it's like pressing,
pressing a volleyball into the water,
press,
press down on a volleyball,
it's going to push back.
So if you keep pressing,
it's gonna push back somewhere else and it lifts up your hips and legs.
Got It.
And that's,
he called that pressing the t because the t was the intersection of your spine
and a,
if you stretch your arms out to the side,
that's us.
Yeah.
So there's Shit I was,
I was spending on maybe talking about this earlier,
but,
uh,
I want to be respectful of your time and I,
I also want to make sure that we chat about your cancer diagnosis.
And I have,
I have some questions about that,
but could you tell people the,
uh,
the origin of the cancer diagnosis and,
perhaps just explain the circumstances?
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm just,
about two years ago,
uh,
I went with two friends,
to Sardinia and we swam from course ago,
which is in France to start.
Danny and I had an unbelievably great swim.
I had,
you know,
I had been not training exceptionally hard for it.
It's a,
it's a 10 mile swim.
Uh,
the water temperature was 64,
65.
Uh,
and it took us four and a half hours and that was stopping every 30 minutes.
So there were seven stops for,
for to have a feed,
which happened to be blueberry soup.
One of my co swimmers was from Sweden and build Bettis blow bars.
Sopa uh,
and um,
just an incredible swim.
One of the best swims in my life.
I,
uh,
and uh,
so I came home and within a week of coming home I,
I got a,
I had my annual physical and my,
my doctor,
uh,
found some irregularities when he examined my prostate and he said,
you need to get a biopsy for me,
urologist.
I went very quickly to get the biopsy and the biopsy turned out to be positive
for cancer and it was what's called a Gleason score of four plus three or seven.
And what's significant about that is the number four in indicates how aggressive
the cancer is.
And four indicated it was an aggressive cancer.
So it was one that needed to be treated.
A lot of,
a lot of times today,
what they try to do is it's just watch and wait as much as possible cause they
overtreated for quite a while.
Uh,
but in my case,
it was clear that I needed to get treatment.
I went to,
I found a surgeon to do a robotic,
a radical robotic prostatectomy.
It's called the Da Vinci Surgery.
And a was scheduled for surgery.
Um,
and uh,
but beforehand he said to get some scans down and one of the scan showed that I
was,
I was already in stage four a that the cancer had already metastasized to my
bones.
So no surgery since then.
It's been treat the systemic,
uh,
so it's two years since I'm a diagnosis.
And this is a,
this ride of cancer I have is called metastatic castration resistant cancer,
which is sort of a nasty term.
Uh,
just means that the first,
the first treatment they give you is hormones and the hormones are meant to
suppress testosterone.
So I have the testosterone have a 66 year old woman now.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it's,
it's a very nasty form of cancer and typically 24 to 30 months survival time
after you are diagnosed.
So that was pretty sobering dose.
How are you,
okay.
Uh,
what did,
what have you seen in yourself?
I mean in our interactions,
at least via email,
text and so on.
And certainly even speaking with you,
I mean,
you,
you seem very,
uh,
beat and optimistic and very engaged with total immersion,
for instance.
Uh,
what changes have you observed in yourself,
just mentally or psychologically since the diagnosis?
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I went through a roller coaster the first,
uh,
six to eight months afterward where,
you know,
first I felt sorry for myself and then the news kept getting worse.
Like I,
I didn't find out that I had the worst variety of prostate cancer right away.
It took a while for the,
for the failure of my,
uh,
my hormone treatment failed in two months.
Uh,
the cancer started growing again and they usually look for two years of,
of,
of cancer suppression from that.
And,
uh,
you know,
my oncologist said,
I said to be straight with me on this doc.
And you said it's the far side of bad nose.
Uh,
so,
you know,
I was going through a rollercoaster where the newest kept getting more sobering
and,
uh,
I,
I was feeling anger,
anxiety,
not depression,
ever.
Never.
Yeah.
Never,
never depression,
but,
uh,
but I felt quite a bit of anxiety to the point where it,
you know,
it'd be,
it was out of control and I,
I sought treatment for anxiety,
which had never thought I would ever need in my life.
Um,
so the first six to eight months where like that,
but then with the help of the antianxiety medication,
I'm on Lexapro and Abilify and I don't mind,
I don't mind admitting it.
It's worked.
Um,
it's enabled me to reclaim who,
who I always was,
which is a person who's driven by a purpose.
And the purpose is to change,
uh,
change the way people swim.
I mean,
literally to change the way swimming is taught and practiced in this world.
Um,
it's an,
I've always had such a powerful sense of purpose and I wake up with that sense
of purpose every day.
And,
and I have to say that in the past,
um,
probably 16 months now,
I haven't experienced any anxiety.
I haven't experienced any depression.
I wake up,
I still wake up every morning fired up to do what I'm going to do that day too,
which today is your podcast
and which,
which I couldn't be happier about.
And I'm thrilled to have you on.
I mean I,
I wish we could spend some more time together.
Um,
so I hope to,
I mean we,
uh,
we,
we had a chance,
which was really exciting for me after learning Tai through the book and seeing
freeze frames,
a view with all the diagrams showing correct direction and so on,
to actually,
uh,
get in the water in Hawaii with Sarah and to swim with you is just such a
highlight for me.
Such,
such a wonderful experience
for May as well.
And I,
I really feel the need to say this about that.
I,
you know,
knowing all you have on your plate and especially in the midst of that TV
production,
uh,
and,
um,
knowing what I know about your,
your hunger to learn new things,
I just had always assumed,
cause you know,
we were,
we were friends from a distance and we met for Medford dinner in San Francisco
one time.
But you know,
we were friends from the distance with periodic contacts.
When you wanted to make another mention,
thank you.
Of total immersion and one of your books,
um,
that when I,
when I arrived in Hawaii,
I was so impressed as to see how strong your hungers remained,
uh,
to improve your swimming.
And I thought like,
you know,
it's not,
it's not a box he wanted to check off at all.
He really cares about this.
So I saw that and I was really impressed and happy about that.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it,
uh,
it's really been a
foundational skill for changing my life for the better.
And furthermore,
I mean,
it's given me this toolkit,
which is very clear,
very counterintuitive,
but very clear with which I've been able to,
uh,
take part of course just drafting on what you're doing.
But in say,
helping Sarah and watching that complete transformation take place,
uh,
and helping some of my friends who I've,
I've run into who say the same thing that I said when I was say 25 and they say,
Oh yeah,
I just don't swim.
No,
I'm just not comfortable in the water.
And usually what I'll say to that is,
well,
why don't we just take an afternoon and come with me to a pool and we'll just
find a lane that's four feet deep and let's fix that.
And they're like,
what?
What do you mean fix it?
But like,
I don't have time
to teach others.
I love that there's nothing I like better.
Uh,
and it's,
and it's just the end.
It's really just getting them to that point that I experienced with total
immersion.
And after the first day of training,
which is,
oh my God,
I can actually do this,
which is,
I mean,
similar to the experience that you had with the drill you did with pressing down
that you now teach us torpedo,
where you realize,
oh my God,
this story that I've been telling myself,
my legs are heavy,
I'm just cursed with heavy legs is completely,
it's either unfounded or completely fixable.
Right?
And what else am I,
what am else else?
Am I capable of changing about my swimming and it's turned out there's nothing I
can change.
Yeah.
Or or your life,
right?
See if this impossible is not just possible,
Like Tim Ferriss cannot swim is not only
possible to fix,
but in fact easy to fix a with the proper counterintuitive teaching and
progression in this cage case,
which is total immersion.
I mean it's,
it's such,
it's such a demonstration.
It's such a profound demonstration of possibility for me that I really encourage
anyone who's listening to this,
and I'll say this also in the intro,
who is
unable to swim or views themselves as being unable to swim or is a poor swimmer
to just try this because it will open your eyes in such a way that you not only
look at swimming and water differently,
but you will,
you will look at other skills in your life differently as well.
Uh,
I mean,
after total immersion,
that's when I started asking myself,
what are the other impossibles,
what are the other things I've told myself I just can't do,
like play basketball or,
or shoot a basketball was another one.
Let me reexamine that.
And then I found,
uh,
a method that is sort of a corollary in a sense to total immersion,
but for basketball,
it turns out,
I think I'm,
I might be getting the name wrong,
but I think it's Rick Torb.
It teaches basketball shooting in a way that you would find very much,
uh,
a close cousin to Tii and it just makes sense.
And I was like,
okay,
wow,
okay.
That's two for two.
Now,
what else is there?
I thought I thought the same thing when you,
when you described your,
your first tennis lesson.
Exactly.
Oh yeah.
My rent late.
And Laura Lorenzo's same story.
The way that he teaches.
Like,
okay,
this immediately makes sense.
It is,
it,
it is perfectly sensible.
And yet I've never seen anyone teach this way.
Uh,
it's uh,
it's,
it's really a gift that you've given and continue to give to the world.
Sell.
I'll bet.
Crazy thing.
No one,
no one else has still teaching this way.
How to,
you know,
we've been doing it for 30 years with incredible success and we're still the
only ones teaching this way.
Why does that,
why is that,
why do you think that is?
It's just a lot of,
a lot of built in
resistance to change in the world.
This one,
yes,
there are in many,
many places and you know,
they,
well,
they believe what matters is how many laps you do and how strong your pulling
kick as they persist in believing that.
And so what is the first thing you learn,
uh,
when,
when you take care of a beginner's lesson is how to kick and how to pull.
And that's,
that's really putting the cart before the horse if you're not comfortable in the
water.
Oh yeah.
I mean that's just do,
that'll just guarantee,
at least in my case that you need to breathe 10 times.
You write more urgently.
Right.
Then you did other ones.
Yeah,
we've,
uh,
you know,
crack the code so to speak and,
and it works.
It just works every single time.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll Terry,
uh,
yeah.
What,
uh,
I want to,
I want to make sure that,
uh,
we,
we wrap up in the next couple of minutes,
but,
uh,
okay.
What would you like to
share with,
uh,
with,
with people who are listening?
In other words,
you know,
if there were recommendations you have,
uh,
certainly checking out total immersion is a no brainer as far as I'm concerned.
Uh,
and we can get to,
uh,
where they can find more on that and so on in a second.
But is there anything else you'd like to convey?
Anything you would encourage people to,
to ask themselves or suggest that they do?
Uh,
since we have,
uh,
quite a few people listening,
I'm sure at this point we haven't,
we haven't gotten too much into the how to make,
maybe I can,
I can share a few,
a few how to suggestions that people can try.
Yeah,
let's do it.
And,
and some principals.
Um,
I always like to go back to first principles for as the basis for anything that
matters.
Anything we care about doing well.
Uh,
and so I'll,
I'll share five first principles of intelligent improvement oriented swimming.
Um,
first is to recognize that as a human swimmer you are in energy wasting machine.
Uh,
the Darpa,
uh,
the defense advanced research projects agency,
in designing a a swim foil for the Navy Seals back in 2005,
they did a,
they did an efficiency estimation for a group of lap swimmers.
These,
these were not,
uh,
tutored or coach swimmers,
but that people think they're pretty okay,
that they swim laps a lot and they found they were only 3% efficient.
97% of their energy was going into something other than locomotion.
So,
so as a human swimmer,
you are naturally an energy wasting machine.
And in everything you do,
focus on saving energy before you focus on increasing fitness at goes back to
what bill boomer said,
conditioning something that happens while you build refiner and print skills.
So that's principle number one.
Principle number two,
most of what we know about swimming is wrong.
All our primal instincts about swimming leaders,
the straight and most of what we hear,
uh,
are,
are not helpful.
So you have really have to exercise critical thinking.
If someone,
uh,
suggest you try something and it doesn't seem to work well,
maybe,
maybe it wasn't a good idea.
Uh,
if they suggest you try some smokes something or Tim [inaudible] to go to the
pool with them in a four foot shallow area,
uh,
and,
and you experience something,
uh,
thereby,
that works then than trust in your trust,
in your own intuition about things.
And don't feel that you have to believe what you hear from authoritative
sources.
Uh,
principle number three,
it's obvious that efficiency is not natural for humans.
Inefficiencies is,
is natural,
but is entirely learnable,
as as Tim discovered in a period of eight weeks where he went from swimming 20
yards in a,
in a pool and being exhausted to swimming a mile in the end,
the ocean,
it's learnable.
Anyone,
anyone can learn to swim with great efficiency and then improve on it
continuously by applying the principles of mastery,
uh,
including love,
the plateau.
A principle number four,
if you want to swim with more ease or more efficiency,
think about what you can do to make your vessels sleeker.
Uh,
and I'll,
when I finished with the five principles,
just mention a three or four simple action items that for the next time you go
to the pool,
but,
but strive for a sleeker vessel,
it's,
it's a universally unquestioned truth among naval architects and scientists who
study fish.
So why should it be different for your body?
Um,
and then finally,
strive,
strive to swim in a way that you,
you use your body as a whole.
Resist any suggestions someone tells you to just pull or Kik or separate the
Poland Keck and you're training a strive for a seamlessly integrated movement
that is based in,
in the core.
So those are five first principle principles worth,
uh,
worth listening to again and writing down I think.
Okay.
And on number five,
just before we get to the action items,
just to give an example of that integration,
that was one of these Aha moments that we've been talking about for me at least,
was the idea that,
uh,
that you not use your legs for propulsion.
So if you don't think about your legs and swimming as a propeller,
but instead use a very small flick of each leg to turn the hips and therefore
turn the shoulders so that you're going from that fuselage right to fuselage,
left and back and forth.
It changes the entire nature of swimming.
Right?
So,
um,
that was,
uh,
that was just one example of integration that I found hugely helpful.
Tell flake illustrates three other principles that I just mentioned.
Human swimmers or energy wasting machine.
So what are you focusing on with,
with a tough lake instead of leg churn,
saving energy.
Uh,
and um,
principle number two,
most of what we know about swimming is wrong.
What did you know about swimming before you learn?
Tai,
what did you know about the kick?
No,
and folks had to use it as a propeller to push me forward.
All right.
And,
and principle number five,
uh,
as,
as you saw,
principle number four is strive for a sleek or vessel.
So rather than focusing on on propulsion and a bigger,
bigger,
stronger Kik,
you lose.
It was the smaller,
lighter kick.
It really worked.
So for the five principles were illustrated by that.
That one thing.
And you know,
the same thing with your hand swapping.
Uh,
you know,
you were what you were accomplishing.
There was a poll that was a little more patient,
a little slower probably,
but,
but by you or using your arms to reduce drag.
Yup,
definitely.
And it also,
it also helps pull together the pieces in terms of integrating your stroke.
Just that timing is one of the things that the stopping the kick,
which is interrupting your natural rhythm.
But having that
timing in your arms naturally promotes an integrated us,
um,
technique that we're,
all the parts are working together.
So what action items would you have for people who wanted to try something at
the pool?
Yeah,
so action items and I would suggest that you don't swim long distances while
trying these.
Um,
if you can swim anywhere from just about five strokes to a half a lap a and feel
that you're doing it,
that's,
that's good.
You don't have to,
you don't have to leave one end with the,
with an oblong feeling that you're obligated to go to the other end.
So the very first of these would be hang or align your head.
Most important,
the fuck,
the most fundamental thing.
The first thing we always teach is hang or align your head.
Um,
you could,
you could visualize perhaps that there's a toll line attached to the top of your
head pulling your spine directly forward while while you,
you know,
while you do everything that the stroking part of it,
that your spine is always moving forward.
So get your head aligned would be number one.
Number two,
use your arms to lengthen your body,
not to push water back.
You're still going to push water back.
But by using your arms to lengthen your body,
you're promoting two things,
a lower drag profile,
um,
and a complete movement.
You're,
you're focused on completing the movement.
A lot of people think about finishing the stroke backed by the hip.
Finish it to the front instead.
Uh,
the third is the what,
what Tim just mentioned,
um,
which is you cannot go wrong by kicking less.
Just always keep that in mind.
You cannot go wrong by kicking list.
It's a kicking is a great way to burn energy and a great way to create drag.
It's a very poor way to create propulsion.
So those would be,
oh,
and one more.
One more.
Anything you do more quietly is more effective and efficient.
So whatever you're doing at,
at,
at a given moment and the next lap,
strive to do it more quietly and it will be better.
So align your head,
lengthen your body cake last,
swim more quietly for action items.
Yeah,
the,
the swimming quietly is one that if I find myself getting,
uh,
prematurely tired,
which I take as an indication that I'm being inefficient,
that's usually what I'll focus on.
I'll stop.
I'll just rest at the side of the pool for whether it is 30 seconds,
60 seconds,
and then for the next handful of labs just tried to be as silent as possible.
So no splashing with the feed,
with the hands in a really trying to glide the arm in at an angle and to do it
as silently as possible,
uh,
is also one of those exercises that just checks so many different boxes it
seems.
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
uh,
Terry,
this is a,
this has been great.
I'm glad that we were able to find the time to do this.
And uh,
of course people can find total immersion online@totalimmersion.net where they
can find videos and instruction and everything else.
Is there anything that you would like people to check out or anything anywhere
else that people should,
uh,
say hello?
Well,
first of all,
I want to say thank you and I want to say you are a masterful,
an artful podcast host.
I'm working on it,
work in progress,
but thank you.
I felt very well guided.
I would like to do a podcast and I hope,
I hope to be a fraction as good as you are when I,
when I do it so well.
Yeah,
I would like to offer all your podcasts,
listeners of seven day free trial of our online swim academy where there's a
tremendous amount of information and you will have access to every bit of it,
including stroke,
including streaming video and ebooks and all kinds of information.
It's all free.
Everything we have produced is,
is,
is available.
Uh,
and all they have to do is go to total immersion academy.com,
forward slash Tim total immersion academy.com,
forward slash Tim,
uh,
to learn more and take advantage of that offer.
Perfect.
And to everybody listening,
I'll also put that in the show notes,
so if you want to find links to that and everything else we've talked about,
you can find that at tim.blog/podcast and just search Terry's name.
Uh,
if you just search Terry's since he,
I believe you are the only Terry I've interviewed so far than a,
you will pop right up.
And,
uh,
Terry,
it's a,
it's been such an honor and a privilege,
uh,
to,
to have you on and is,
as far as your podcasting hosting progress goes,
I think it's important to,
uh,
if you want a good laugh,
listen to my first episode that I did as a host.
Uh,
and you'll realize just how much one can improve
any scale is improvable.
Boy.
Oh yeah.
So not,
I think that,
uh,
if you use my first episode as a,
as a hurdle,
I think that you'll clear it with flying colors.
You're already much better than I was then.
Uh,
so don't be daunted by that and I hope to hear your podcast soon myself.
But Terry,
thank you so much for taking the time.
I really,
really appreciate it and thank you so much for inviting me.
It's a pleasure,
pleasure and a privilege.
I really looked forward to and to everybody listening,
try out total immersion,
uh,
honestly,
whether you're a swimmer or a non swimmer or someone who has never quite been as
comfortable as you would like.
I,
I am not,
if you've seen photos of me,
uh,
what you had to think of as built for swimming.
And I told myself all sorts of handicapping stories and accepted all types of
partial completeness until my thirties.
When I used accountability by,
uh,
having a friend assign me a new year's resolution.
I knew he would bust my balls forever if I didn't do it,
uh,
to get me to finally take it seriously.
And taking it seriously meant I took all sorts of classes and so on and wasted a
lot of time trying things that were really,
really,
really hard like kickboards and everything else.
It doesn't have to be hard and in fact a good instruction should seem very,
very clear and it should make a lot of sense.
And that's what I got from total immersion and I can,
I can go down a long list of my friends who have since learned how to swim.
Uh,
so definitely check it out.
And Terry,
you mentioned it already,
but total immersion academy.com forward slash Tim,
I really hope people give it a test and share their experiences because it's,
it can really be regulatory and to everyone listening,
as always,
until next time,
thank you for tuning in.
Be Safe out there,
question assumptions and never stop learning.
Okay guys,
that's the end of the first interview.
And from this point forward you will hear several clips of Terry's daughters,
Fiona,
Carrie,
and Betsy interviewing him in the hospital in the days before his passing.
Thanks for listening.
What do you want to make sure that's not written down yet?
So you're talking about is what makes total immersion distinctive.
Yeah,
I got that.
Yeah.
Is,
is teaching balance as the,
the t skill was farming.
No one else even recognizes as a skill.
Okay.
Let alone the keystones skill of swimming efficiently or not just sewing
efficiently of being able to enjoy swimming,
being able to swim with ease,
grace and enjoyment.
A lot of these are,
and we will approach it to demonstrate that the total immersion way is uniquely
unique and promoting all those ancillary benefits because we do it consciously
because we're trying to develop the whole person,
not just the swimmer.
Okay.
We're trying to grow the whole person.
Hello
Brain,
psyche and body done.
Let me ask you a question.
Is there anything you want to convey to other people about house house swimming?
You're approach is helping you right now?
Like interval training with this?
That's a good shot.
Sure.
Everything.
Everything I've practiced and taught has helped prepare me for this crisis
moment in my life.
Okay.
Can you give some examples?
Sure.
Your mindfulness
process orientation.
MMM.
Like the way that you're drinking,
right?
Focus points.
Vocal points.
Say what your focus points.
We're drinking our mind by mindfulness.
Casa.
Sorry.
I'm used to doing things a guided by phone call points and attentive to
Foucault.
Clients.
Talk about your experience with learning to drink.
I try to talk about that.
I have to learn after my stroke I have to learn to drink all over again and I'm
applying the same prices,
learning,
reteaching myself how to drink.
That applied to teaching myself how to breathe seamlessly while swimming
freestyle.
So that's your focus point.
Break it down.
Yeah,
because this would be really helpful.
So my focal points for drinking our
sip.
Exhale,
relax,
swallow,
repeat,
hi.
Then rest interval and rest interval and your treat those like you treat repeats
when you're swimming in the pool.
She has.
I do exactly recognizing that what I'm doing is draining my brain because parts
of my brain had been injured.
Parts of my brain that controls swallowing properly and not aspirating,
have been injured and I have to train new neuron just to take over that task.
And the only way to do it is with a conscious process,
right.
Where I connect the motor and cognitive neurons that are associated with that
tivity yeah.
About the,
what about the emotional cost that the important points and emotional aspects is
to be nonjudgmental of this experience.
Making mistakes is making mistakes is essential to learning.
So that when I make a mistake that I can recognize the mistake that I can,
I can,
uh,
analyze the mistake.
I,
the only way to avoid it in the future is to recognize it,
analyze it,
and,
and then,
and then come up with a strategy to avoid it.
Right?
Yeah.
How do I do that by saying,
recognizing that I have to exhale before swallowing.
Okay.
But what about the emotional aspect?
Close the epiglottitis
yes.
That's more technical though.
I mean like fear,
anxiety,
anything like that.
Do you feel like your,
uh,
your practice
detached almost clinical place you are and doing this?
Because my metaphor,
you're splitting,
right?
You're sitting English 10 or English Channel.
You're swinging around Manhattan.
Yeah.
Right.
And you're in rough water and you're struggling right now.
Recovering from a stroke to recover from a stroke is like training to swim
around Manhattan.
So when you enter a rough water,
there's a lot of turbulence around you,
which there isn't it right down slower,
the ones around you,
how would you compare that to what's going on in your mind when you're swimming
in turbulent water versus being in a room with a lot of refer?
The water is rough for the water or the more turbulent my surroundings,
the calmer I have to be here.
You have to think about how this is going to start rolling external turbulence
and internal comm and there has to be the more external turbulence I camera,
the more Entercom I must cultivate.
All right.
Is there anything else you want us to want to talk about as far as,
yeah,
you want to get that so you still had to,
well,
no,
I think a very important element in this book is the fact that I'm writing the
entire book was stage four cancer.
Yes.
And dealing with things like strokes.
Yeah.
As I'm,
as I'm writing the book,
Yeah.
That's going to,
that's going to be in the intro.
Yeah.
We want that to be prominent.
Absolutely.
Readers and potential readers to know this as they're thinking about how we use
as they're contemplating,
because not everybody will have an order read the book and how do you feel like
people can apply that?
A lot of the interviews of the bug,
but how do you feel,
how do you think that knowledge people can apply that to themselves and
understanding that it's not about ideal circumstances?
It'll add an element of drama.
Yeah.
Right.
Life drama.
It'll add an element of life's problems and your bracelet.
Okay.
Hold on.
How am I different person writing this book?
Then the person that wrote the original book.
Okay.
Big.
A big part of it.
How are you a different person?
Yes.
Well I'm,
I'm 65 and 66 I was 45 then.
Yeah.
What am I life experiences that I'm bringing to it this time?
Talk about that.
We'll stage four cancer and this stuff that's come with it.
Okay.
And Dad,
I think it's also important to know what is going on right now,
which is very serious and they've told us is,
is it's life threatening,
but you,
you know,
you've said and saying this is not the end and you're going to get through this.
I'm going to get through this.
Yeah.
And many more healthy years.
Good friends.
My,
my,
my practice and work and everything I've been teaching has helped prepared me
for this.
Like almost nothing else that I could have done.
Yes.
What I'm,
what I'm teaching you in this book.
Okay.
We need it.
Nope.
Can I interject something because we talked about this yesterday.
You have significant brain swelling.
And we were talking about visualizing,
you said visualizing a skinny brain,
which was a joke,
but really the idea of visualize meditating and visualizing on your brain
swelled decreasing.
Do you want to talk about that?
Have you been doing that?
The physical process by which that happens?
I needed to understand the physical process by which that happens in order to be
able to visualize it.
So did the doctor help me and that helped do this.
Helen Ellen MCU helped also.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Helen's been very,
very helpful here
in my conversation with the various physicians who come through.
She came specifically to be the medical translator.
I'm not sure she did.
Yeah,
she said that
she's very,
very good at that.
Okay.
Let me just finish this thought.
Can you describe your view of any visualization technique that you have used
since you've been here?
Sure.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Same,
same blood flow through my brain
and uh,
keep,
keep trying to look that way.
Excess
excess moisture and my brain tissues being drawn into the bloodstream and
carried out of the brain to be graded.
And how often have you been doing the visualization?
Once a day.
Twice a day.
Oh,
I'm on and
off.
On and off.
Not on a schedule.
Okay.
Yeah.
Whenever you have a quiet moment.
What about the value of rest?
What about the value of breast quality over quantity and the value of
breastfeeding?
Because you emphasize that was swimming too.
It's about quality a lot of times.
Not Quantified.
I don't know.
I haven't thought about it.
Okay.
Well remember when they tell them that the most important element of my recovery
is rest and sleep.
Yeah.
They,
the doctors here.
So I see a connecting thread with that and your other,
yeah.
No,
you're not.
The injuries that you had during the year that you broke all those records,
dad.
Yeah.
And remember how you weren't able to train as much.
All right.
So don't you see that as a similarity?
Yeah,
I actually got a lot more arrest.
That's a good point.
Could you talk towards the phone cause I,
it's the microphone's over here,
right.
That was in forest rest that year.
And for stress actually enabled you to swim better enforced rest.
Which we've been making sure that you get enough rest and sleep.
You're doing way better today than you were before.
What do you mean?
Meaning
we can see improvements in you from the other day after?
Yes.
What?
Sorry?
You're more alert and awake for longer periods of time.
You can speak at length that the first day we could barely wake you up,
so you needed to rest.
Yeah.
So there's a connection there.
My body needed to rush the first day for stress too.
It was
like I had undergone a lot of stress on Tuesday.
Yeah.
So,
so it was recovering on Wednesday.
Okay.
So the importance of rest and recovery in some practice from the stress of the
stroke.
Right.
Tuesday and recovery.
Sorry,
sorry,
sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm ready.